Not that we needed more examples of huge corporations
using Donald Trump's corporate tax cut to
pump up the price of their own stock.
But we have another example and it's Texas
instruments. They make those, remember those
graphing calculators from high school and
college that you could sometimes install tetracycline
and instead of doing differential equations,
you were actually playing tetris much to the,
uh, um, uh, ignorance of the professor, which
of course now is common. Um, uh, that's what
everybody's doing on their laptops at this
point in college. At the time it was kind
of novel. The company that makes those graphing
calculators is Texas instruments and they
spent five point $1 billion repurchasing shares
of their own stock that is twice the amount
that they spent the year before and more than
any other Texas company in the s and p 500
index. It just so happens that under Trump's
tax plan, their tax rate, their effective
tax rate dropped from 39% in 2017 to 17% in
2018 overall companies in the s and p 500
saw an effective tax rate decrease of seven
percentage points on average and tons of those
companies are using that extra money simply
to pump up the price of their own stock by
repurchasing shares, which benefits, as I've
told you before, their shareholders and their
executives, the richer they are, the more
they benefit from pumping their own stock.
Texas Instruments wrote in their 10 k filing
that quote. Our strategy is to return all
free cashflow to shareholders which is in
black and white. A very different strategy
than using money to hire people using the
money to increase salaries using the tax cut
for all of the types of winning that we were
told would come from Donald Trump's tax guts.
Now Texas instruments did make a modest increase
to their capital expenses, some of which would
be reasonably said to fall under the umbrella
of reinvesting in the company, but it's small
potatoes compared to the billions that went
into just buying back shares of stock and
it's one of those stories where yet none of
it is surprising like if you were paying attention,
this is exactly what we were predicting. This
is what always happens and it's going to get
even worse. Check out this chart comparing
hourly wages to productivity.
What you might notice, and I'll describe it
to you, is that up until about 1973 wages
and productivity went up basically in parallel
as workers became more productive, their wages
went up roughly in proportion to those productivity
increases. And then in 1973 that splits and
hourly wages go up. Only 9% since 1973 while
productivity is up 72% now this is partially
technology and this is why the interests of
workers and their employers are no longer
aligned for lots of companies, their biggest
expense is wages. For employees to increase
their stock price, they need to cut expenses
or increased productivity without parallel
increases to wages and that is exactly what
they're doing and it's only going to get worse
with technological automation destroying more
jobs. Machine learning is going to destroy
jobs. Artificial intelligence is going to
accelerate this and there's a really good
book I'm reading right now.
I believe the book is a year or two old, it's
called life 3.0 by Max Tegmark and it's all
about machine learning and artificial intelligence
and much of it focuses on the impact on jobs.
I really recommend the book, but none of this
is surprising and when you zoom out, it's
not surprising that Donald Trump's tax cuts
are not boosting the economy so much that
we're making all of the money back that we
are giving in tax cuts. Trump said, yes, the
tax cuts reduce government revenue, but they
will stimulate so much economic growth that
then we would make up for that. It's not happening.
The debt has exploded. The deficit has exploded
and their boy therefore has grown the debt
even more quickly, and every element of this
was predictable. All along. None of this is
surprising. If you're surprised by this, you
either weren't paying attention, don't understand
how this stuff works, or we're deliberately
pretending like it was going to go differently
under Donald Trump than it has every time
in American history that this type of economic
policy has been adapted through the tax code.
Tell me where I'm wrong. Make sure you're
following the David Pakman show on Instagram
at David Pakman show and follow me on Instagram
as well at David Dot. Pacman. Some very good,
a a behind the scenes videos from the studio
that I posted yesterday that are extraordinarily
titillated
by
Trump goes up